La volta al món a peu, dia 267.
Bueno, mireu on estic, tu.
Mireu on estic com ha canviat el paisatge, eh?
Bueno, s'ha deixat ser les muntanyes així una mica pelades.
Això és una espècie de complex abandonat que han deixat aquí.
I bueno, jo entre aquestes tres parets he dormit protegit del vent.
Era pla, era baixa.
Molt bé, la veritat, no hi havia pedres.
Molt bé.
I mireu quines vistes al despertar.
Pa!
Mira la neu, eh?
N'havíem vist molt poca, eh, en aquest país.
Només quan vaig posar allà el llac aquell tan guapo.
Molt guapo, tu.
Aquesta nit ha plogut, suposo que aquesta neu és d'altres dies.
Per aquestes muntanyes crec que som 4.000, no ho sé.
Però ha plogut i ha plogut fang, clar.
Com aquí hi ha tanta pols en aquest país,
jo crec que sempre que plou, deu ploure fang.
I estar a la tenda, doncs...
Pots plenar de fang.
Sí, sí, sí, sí.
Bueno, ahir vaig caminar, no vaig fer vídeo.
Va ser un dia poc destacable.
Després us explico més.
Gràcies.
Subtítols per la comunitat Amara.org
Què canvi de paisatge, eh!
Hem passat de caminar per la carretera que hi ha de tres carrils superment asfaltada
a aquesta pista sense asfaltar,
i per aquesta vall, tu.
Aquesta vall que té el riu sota,
que baixa molt caudalós, molt, molt, molt,
molta aigua...
Molt maco, també.
Passatge molt impressionant.
Sí, sí.
Molt interessant.
Impressionant, no hi ha absolutament res, no hi ha ningú, bueno, van passant cotxes.
De fet, un cotxe m'ha donat aigua i diversos cotxes s'han oferit a portar-me.
I és una vall que té algun poble, però crec que el primer poble està a 20 quilòmetres, no ho tinc clar, potser menys.
Però bueno, alguns pobles hi ha, flipo amb que la gent per comunicar-se amb la civilització
hagi d'anar per aquesta pista durant quilòmetres i quilòmetres i quilòmetres.
Però bueno, suposo que val la pena per viure aquí, no ho sé.
Eh, ahir què? Ahir el més destacat del dia va ser que no va fer sol.
Em desperto i veig això, pum, us he fet una foto, i tot el dia va fer núvols.
Va ser genial, a més va haver-hi una caiguda dràstica de temperatura, 6 graus menys, marcava l'aplicació,
i vaig caminar superbé. Va ser el dia que vaig caminar millor des que estic a Tajikistan,
perquè clar, no feia calor, no feia sol.
Això sí, va ser molt avorrit, va ser caminar per carretera, pum, pum, pum.
I vaig deixar enrere aquella part del... totes aquelles dues carreteres que us vaig explicar,
que anaven paral·leles, el pantà aquell que estàvem fent, etcètera.
Vaig veure bastants xinesos treballant en la construcció d'això, i tal.
I bueno, ara el tema és recórrer aquesta vall, 60 quilòmetres, bastant pla, encara que bueno, va fent pujada i baixada.
I un cop passat aquests 60 quilòmetres ve un port de muntanya en el que hauria de pujar 1.600 metres positius.
I allà entrarem oficialment a la regió del Pamir, però bueno, això ja serà demà o demà passat.
Mira, uns gossos, gossos pastor. Tenia el pastor ja, que ha passat de tot.
No sé si ho veies això, cabres.
Aquí en aquest país són negres, totes.
Crec que és una altra espècie, no sé.
Bueno, els gossos aquests què fan?
M'han bordat una mica, però bueno, crec que res, eh?
Bé.
Aquí tenim el pastor.
Ara se n'ha amagat.
Bueno.
Hello.
Vale.
Ara el pastor ha vingut i ha dit, ei, i ja està.
Molt tranquils.
No ha gallinat sabent ticket, oso.
Sí.
I crec que és un perill de clar, elf backgrounds...,
sí.
Demà acaba que están futes les lesionades, per exemple en aquest percentatge,
és evident la complexitat, en qualsevol situació no caldria moure's de les lesions.
Sí.
Bé.
No rebals diets i scenes segur, i si me l'ha pagat, al masters s'ha ficat molt bonic.
I no 까 bé que es vagi fer una televisió d'aquesta edat.
A veure si d'abans ha 1972.
Sí.
Ara tuning ears!
És prévi.
Sí.
Brutal, brutal. Crec que mai havia vist tantes ovelles juntes.
I sí, sí, sí, són ovelles negres, eh?
Aquí la Covid que hi ha a l'Eugeni no funciona.
Algunes són pelmes roses, però sí, sí, alguns són com cabrits, no?
Tenen banyes, no sé, algú em pot dir quin animal és aquest? És una ovella, no?
Increïble. Són moltíssimes, eh? No s'acaba, eh?
I allà, allà, allà, venen un...
Hi ha dues coses que s'han hagut de parar, tu.
Màgic, màgic.
Bueno, estem arribant a un poble, aquí, a una peça de piscina natural.
És un llac, no? No ho sé.
Que guapo, eh?
Però, malauradament, que aquí no hi ha un supermercat, aquí.
I tinc bastanta gana. Encara queden 5 quilòmetres per supermercat.
Avui estic bastant low energy, aquest matí.
A veure si em recupero una mica després per la tarda, perquè...
Salom.
Perquè això, he fet 16 quilòmetres, que low.
16 quilòmetres.
Són les 11 i pico.
I això, poques ganes.
Bueno, he parat al minimàrquet aquest, el primer que hi havia.
Però realment només tenien gelats, galetes, carnels,
unes bosses petites de patates fregides.
No tenien absolutament res.
Llavors, en realitat m'ha descarat una estona més a descansar.
Però el mapa em marca que hi ha un altre supermercat.
D'aquí a un quilòmetre, a veure si puc menjar alguna cosa més consistent.
Ho dubto, eh, perquè aquests llocs, els supermercats d'aquests països, no.
És que no hi ha res.
No hi ha res.
Hi ha patates, hi ha menjar cru, entre cometes, verdures, tal, però...
No, jo no puc cuinar-ho.
Bueno, a veure què trobo.
Restaurants no n'hi ha.
Això també és.
Aquí no.
En Motalip, the owner of this shop, he speaks very good English.
Where did you learn it?
Yeah, a little bit, I think.
Where did you learn so good English?
In university.
University?
In Dushanbe?
Dushanbe, yeah.
Very good, very good.
Well, he has this very nice shop.
I just bought some chips.
Very nice.
You were born here?
You were born in this valley?
Yeah.
What's the name of this valley?
Damop.
Damop, eh?
The name of this valley.
And after this, after the pass?
After the pass...
It's Pamir?
Pamir, yeah.
Yeah.
After this village is Pamir.
And how is Pamir?
Because I'm going there and I'm a little scared because it's like a lot of wind and cold.
Or is it not that bad?
Yeah, Pamir is so cool.
Cold, eh?
Cool and cold.
Ai, ai, ai.
Just good.
Well, thank you very much, eh?
Thank you so.
Les dues i vint, tampoc he parat aquí.
Porto vint-i-dos i pico quilòmetres.
Quan arribo als vint, normalment és la xifra com dir, ei, pum, ja he fet vint.
Ja em queda menys de la meitat, deuria, no?
I llavors ja calculo més o menys a l'hora que he fet els vint, ja calculo com vaig bé, no vaig tan bé, tal.
I bueno, avui, tenint en compte que m'he llevat una mica més tard, estic així una mica sense energia, com us he dit, doncs trobo que anem bé.
Trobo que anem bé.
Doncs no m'he parat allà, saps per què?
Sí, hi havia un lloc per sentar-se molt guai, hi havia aquells que parlava anglès.
Però m'han dit que d'aquí dos com a pico quilòmetres hi ha internet.
De megafon.
Hello.
Curiós.
Curiós mitjà de transport.
Llavors, bueno, doncs home, si puc parar on hi ha internet, parlar amb amics, família, actualitzar l'Instagram, doncs sempre està bé, havia de pujar un vídeo.
Sempre, sempre està bé.
Bueno, s'ha amagat una mica els núvols.
Està bé, mireu aquesta vall, aquestes planes aquí.
No és tan agradable aquest lloc, sí.
Trobo que estic una mica sense veu, no?
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
Són les 5 menys 10, ja 30 quilòmetres.
Què tal aquesta vall? Guai, eh?
Hello.
S'ho joquisó.
La peix.
crec que m'han preguntat si era de Tadjikistan
va peix
va peix és endavant
és com una mica el lema no oficial de Tadjikistan
Tadjikistan va peix, Tadjikistan endavant
ho vaig haver de dir el segon dia d'estar aquí
bueno, molt maca aquesta vall
com dic
més a aquesta hora que està el sol ja una mica baix
i dona més
molt bé, i tenim una mesquita aquí també
ja una cosa que no he dit
aprofito per explicar avui aquest teva
hem vist molt poques mesquites
jo no he anat dient, ostres una mesquita
no era com a Turquia
que a dos per tres hi havia una mesquita
aquí no, a part
com veieu és molt diferent perquè els
els minarets, suposant que això és un minaret
no són aquests minarets
els minarets alts i no sé
a veure què passa
els països que acaben anant estant
els països d'aquí de l'àrea central, Uzbekistan, Tajikistan
Kyrgyzstan, Kazakstan
són molt desconeguts per nosaltres
Afganistan i Pakistan
són els dos països que més coneixem
i els associem molt a
corrents de pensament
islàmic, musulmà
molt intenses
alguns dirien radicals
en el cas d'Afganistan especialment
però a Pakistan ja veurem
quan arribem allà que són
molt religiosos
molt islamistes
aquí a Tajikistan llavors
clar, com la gent no coneix res de Tajikistan
ni d'Uzbekistan, la gent
com veu que acaben estant
ja pensa que és un país
així, un país molt musulmà
i no, no és el cas
és més, és el contrari
és un país musulmà però
el govern de l'excel·lentíssim
ostres ara diré malament el nom
no vull dir-lo, és igual
el president de Tajikistan
que porta ja
bastant de temps manant
doncs ha ficat moltes mesures perquè
el país no es torni un país
diríem dir radical o no es radicalitzi
i sí, sí
i bueno, aquí
la gent és musulmana
però no és tant això
per exemple mesures, per exemple
no està permès, bueno, no està recomanat
no és obligatori però no està recomanat
portar la barba llarga
amb els homes
llavors l'hem vist homes que la portaven
però ha passat que la policia
doncs ha agafat la gent
que veia amb la barba llarga
els ha portat a la comissaria
i els ha fet la barba llarga
i això ho és
ho he llegit per internet
i les dones, bueno, les dones porten
l'estimenta típica tajika
que és la que recomana el govern
estan bastant tapades
però no tan tapades com les dones àrabs
el jihab
que és el bel
al Tajikistan
cobreix el cabell però no
no cobreix molt tampoc, vull dir
es veu una mica cabell i no és allò que tapa tot
el que estem acostumats a veure
a Catalunya
que és el que porten normalment les dones marroquines
cobreix per sota la barbeta
d'acord
i tapa molt més, no es veu res de cabell
només es veu la cara, no?
això aquí està prohibit també, bueno
no recomanat
el mateix que amb la barba
aquí no sé ja si
si ha passat que
que la policia hagi fet res
jo he vist igualment a dones
amb el jihab aquest, d'acord?
he vist a dones
vestides no de la manera tradicional tajika
bueno
en tot cas el govern
no vol que això se li envagi de mara
i intenta d'això
us sorprèn?
a molts us sorprendrà, a molts us sorprendrà perquè
jo recordo estant cap al viatge
dient que aniré cap a Uzbekistan i Tajikistan
i les gent feia
ui, aquests països
compte que tallen el coi
no sé què, com fent entendre que
són països molt radicals, no?
doncs no, no és el cas
aquí darrere tinc l'últim supermercat del dia
crec, sí perquè són les 5
i crec que tal, bueno
m'aprovisionaré de menjar a escombraries
que trobi
menys mal, no l'he d'ensenyar, però menys mal
que hi ha gent que ven fruita pel camí
i normalment la compro, me la menjo
i tal, les peres
les peres són boníssimes
les 18 i 18
moment de buscar un lloc d'acampada
aquí és el lloc ideal
per fer servir l'aplicació iOverlander
que us he parlat diverses vegades
perquè realment aquest és el lloc
overlander, aquest és el lloc on
venen la gent amb els 4x4
o el que siguin a fer aventures
després una aplicació que
també la ven servir els senderistes
i sobretot la gent que va amb bicicleta
està molt bé
i aquí hi ha molta gent que diu acampa aquí
acampa allà, bueno el primer lloc d'acampada
seria aquest
com es veu és un
un cobert
un cobert i estaria bé
si hagués de ploure estaria bé
però si no està just al costat
de la carretera
zero privacitat
i avui vull passar-me una aigua
vull despullar-me i home
aquí és molt descarat
i
prefereixo que no estigui tant al costat de la carretera
el segon lloc seria
en aquesta plana
si
en aquesta plana en algun lloc
bueno hi ha varios aquí
que han dit que han acampat per aquí
home està bé és molt pla
que vistes de la carretera si
que passa és que
és com que el cotxe
ha de fer així i mirar saps
si
tampoc m'acaba d'enamorar
perquè per exemple aquí darrere hi ha un noi
un home hello
i clar si ara em despullo és molt del pal
el següent lloc que és bastant millor
i he vist està malauradament
a 4 km
que no em ve de gust caminar tant
no sé
m'ho penso
aquí tenim l'àrea plana aquesta que hem dit
i crec que intentaré
pujar aquí dalt
aquí hi ha com una carretereta
una pista
intentaré pujar aquí dalt a veure si trobo un lloc una mica pla
amb una mica més de privacitat
a veure a veure eh
no té mala pinta veig petjades de vaca
evidentment
un lloc pla va
ai
perfecte no
aquí sembla molt pla però no està pla
però allà
jo crec que sí
a veure jo ara mateix veig la carretera
per tant em podrien veure a mi
però és rotllo
està molt lluny saps
tampoc s'hi fixarà ningú
100% pla no és eh
no no no, no és com allà baix
però bueno
a veure que aquí o allà
algo trobarem
acampo un dutxo i fem resum
dutxa feta
bones vistes avui eh
molt guai tu
no és allò una glacera
a pics de 4.000 m però és una vall molt bé
amb la porta oberta això sempre està bé
sensació de respirar
molt maco tenim antenes
però només són de 3G
2026 i estem amb antenes de 3G
encara
i la lluna allà
bastant creixent ja
molt bé 36 quilòmetres
llascats
800 de desnivell positiu
he parlat amb unes 6 persones
3 d'elles no les he gravat
eren turistes britànics
que van fer un viatge en bicicleta
quan estic baix d'energia
em costa més treure la càmera i
gravar amb gent
bueno avui estava una mica baix d'energia
cap cafè cap te un refresc
i m'he gastat uns
8 euros diria
bueno
8 euros entre supermercats i supermercats
doncs això
ha sigut un dia que ha estat bé
no he tingut l'actitud més
somrient
i positiva però
és un dia que no ha fet molta calor
el paisatge ha estat maco
i ha estat bé
ara m'agradaria dir-vos una cosa
que fa temps que tinc al cap
però no sé si dir-vos-ho
és una demanda
no m'envieu tants missatges privats a l'Instagram
la majoria de missatges privats
que rebo podrien ser comentaris
del Youtube o de l'Instagram
tipus ei m'ha agradat molt el vídeo d'avui
ei endavant Enric
anims
jo sé que ho feu de super bona fe
però què passa
normalment no tinc gaire cobertura ni massa temps
llavors
quan obro l'Instagram
per llegir els missatges privats
doncs veig que tinc un munt
i molts cops dic
no els responc i ja està
què m'ha passat alguna vegada
que dintre d'aquests missatges privats
hi havia algun missatge important
per exemple quan estava a Uzbekistan
hi havia una persona que estava a Uzbekistan
i com no vaig llegir el seu missatge
perquè n'hi havia molts d'altres
que eren
no importants
no eren d'aquests
doncs vaig saltar aquesta persona
i no me la vaig trobar
i per culpa d'això no la vaig trobar
llavors jo us demano que si el missatge
podria ser un comentari
si el missatge podria ser un comentari del Youtube
no és una cosa molt privada ni una cosa molt important
doncs talleu-vos una mica
jo sé que ho feu de bona fe però
però tal
a més a més
si m'envies un missatge privat
només ho poden llegir tu i jo
en canvi si el fiques com a comentari
el pot llegir tothom
una cosa més comunitària
tinc 10.000 visites als vídeos
10.000 persones que podien llegir el comentari
si és una cosa interessant doncs pot estar bé
vinga
bona nit